hallo
[Musik]
ich liebe es so hier zu sein
unglaublich das ist so friedlich und
drückt irgendwie alles in perspektive
egal was für probleme du in deinem
alltag hast du hast du dich rum er gast
keine ahnung weil mir zeigen welche
zahlungsanbieter die nicht funktionieren
die mich den ganzen tag irgendwie um den
verstand bringen und dann bin ich hier
und es ist scheißegal was mit
irgendwelchen zahlungsanbieter nicht
wenn du dir die ziegen anschaut dann
denkst du was es denn wichtig im leben
das du nun ein schönes plätzchen hast du
in der sonne liegen kannst desto gutes
essen haft frisches wasser und in der
hand ob und guter gesellschaft
manchmal habe ich gar keine lust hat zu
kommen weil ich so viele andere sachen
zu tun habe aber egal wie groß die
überwindung ist auch schwanger zu
steigen und herzufahren
sobald ich hier bin genieße ich es
komplett und sobald die tiere versorgt
sind da geht es für mich dann an die
arbeit und viele von euch wissen glaube
ich gar nicht das große werk und ich
mein job ist und nicht nur meinen job
sondern ich auch ein ganz schön großes
team habe mittlerweile das mich
unterstützt die videos zu machen in den
blog zu schreiben und auch unsere kurse
zu erstellen
[Musik]
ich bin aufgeregt und diese woche
arbeiten wir noch ganz fleißig am obst
und gemüse haltbar machen kurs der säule
am samstag online gehen am 24 es ist
noch jede menge zu tun dass dahin
es hat auf jeden fall jede menge spaß
gemacht die kurzvideos geben aber die
müssen eben jetzt auch noch alle
geschnitten werden und die ganzen
checklisten und rezepte müssen noch
überarbeitet werden und am ende soll
natürlich auch alles dann richtig
perfekt sein
so sieht es aus wenn ich vor der kamera
stehe also der bildausschnitt aber ich
zeige euch mal nicht in rund herum
aussieht
das ist vergessen das kleid das ich
gleich anziehen muss das lüge leisen
dass ich frau kommen das braucht ein
bisschen schön zu machen irgendwelche
einkauf etiketten jede menge einkauft
leser francisco das ist jetzt der zweite
tag in dem ich vollzeit nur an diesem
einen video schneide
langsam kann ich nicht selbst echt nicht
mehr sehen
[Musik]
wir müssen jetzt über sich selbst zu
lachen reden wichtig dass zumindest der
großteil davon am samstag dahin schon
ein gepflegt ist damit die längste
absitzen
[Musik]
erste hat übrigens fabi kaputt gemacht
der ist hier die treppe runtergefallen
dann dagegen die tür gefallen er hatte
einen kratzer
die tür war kaputt der gute draht
stärker halte abend arbeite ich mal
woanders und habe jemand in dem
wahrscheinlich viele von euch kennen
sagen ich kenne ich schon einige
[Musik]
[Applaus]
was steckt im boden entsteht eine
funktion an welchem tag versinken die
meisten boote sagte aber meine auch
nicht mehr das niveau aber so fasst
sodann kann also nicht das niveau
ich hab mal beim nichts vorbei kann eine
antifa zeigen
als dankeschön für 12 20 uhr 22 sitzen
immer noch hier was machen wir decken
wir haben das neue forum endlich online
und jetzt versuchen wir doch eine
csv-datei zu exportieren wir für euch
alten hasen aber freude viermal
aufgenommen besuchen ist superschön
ja ich merke gerade in zeiten muss so
viel zu tun gibt wie im moment dass es
mir super wichtig ist nach der arbeit in
den garten zu gehen und wie gut es tut
da runter zu kommen und wie gut es tut
etwas zu kochen sich die zeit zu nehmen
essen zuzubereiten das richtig lecker
ist das mit netten menschen zusammen zu
genießen
und auch wenn dieses gartenjahr ziemlich
langweilig ist wenn alles irgendwie ein
bisschen länger dauert setzt jetzt
gerade bei uns gerichte gelernte
schwämme 1
das heißt es geht auch wieder als
haltbar machen - bis bin da sehr
meditative angelegenheit die er in die
küche zu tragen in gläser zu füllen
einzukochen leckere marmeladen und
andere köstlichkeiten zu kochen und wenn
die ganze küche vollstedt mit
blubbernden verwenden
das ist einfach die beste zeit im jahr
ich darf jetzt zum ersten mal das frisch
dieser hinter rezepte geben anschauen
sehr gespannt einfach richtig cool
[Musik]
also ich möchte vor allem das design und
die gestaltung für wurzelwerk also vor
allem sind das im kurs die pdfs gemacht
wie das ewige zu den halter machen kurz
und das ist richtig schön und ich halte
das rudel zusammen würde ich sagen passt
auf dass für so in die richtige richtung
galoppieren und arbeitszeitmodelle
zusammen und passt auf dass wir uns
nicht so viel projekten pinzette die
machen das ganz toll
[Musik]
es ist freitagabend wie ist der stand es
gibt da seht ihr die ganzen module mit
den einzelnen videos das rezept niveau
mit den ganzen leckeren rezepten und wir
freuen uns total teilnehmer dabei
[Musik]